my husband used to call me a nocturnal
animal guys again are all getting Oscar
buzz already I think it was ten years
ago you were nominated for Brokeback
Mountain do you think about if that
could happen again with this one is the
award season stuff something that goes
through your mind honestly it's really
it's nerves at the time that that
happened to me I was I was pretty young
and it was an extraordinary honor at
that age and it's just ordinary on at
any age it's an incredible community of
people the coolest thing about that and
about sort of awards generally is that
it puts you within a group of people and
within history of people who have who
you admire and to even be in a
discussion even with you ask me that
question
is is a nice thing regardless did you
love him I did something horrible to him
this movie is so much about love is
there anything more painful to get
through than love I mean how do you get
through heartbreak what's your advice we
are all in one way or another different
stages you know experiencing heartbreak
of all different kinds socially
politically in our own relationships and
over time I think it's always those
things that when we face them when we
look at them make us stronger and I
think ultimately you look back and you
say now that you're glad for it but that
you know it shaped you into who you are
so I think this movie is is I like that
you say that it's about love because I
believe it is to a lot of people
sometimes ask me if it's about revenge
and I don't think it's about revenge at
all I don't think that's a solution ever
you